bonsoir nous sommes en direct vous venez
de le suivre l'interview d'Emmanuel
Macron par Caroline Roux pour France 2
pour l'événement une émission appelée
les urgences françaises il y a deux
semaines on parlait d'international
aujourd'hui on a parlé de la France et
pour parler de tout ce qui s'est dit
aujourd'hui je suis avec Christophe de
Vogue bonjour Christophe bonjour
spécialiste de rhétorique politique
storia on va parler avec vous un peu de
tout ce qui s'est dit de ce qui sait
aussi pas dit vous êtes du Figaro vous
n'hésitez pas tout au long de ce live
bien sûr à poser vos questions on y
répond au mieux comme d'habitude
Christophe déjà une question un peu
globale qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce qu'il
faut retenir selon vous de cette
interview d'Emmanuel Macron là c'est une
interview j'allais vous renvoyer la
question c'est une interview qui est qui
est longue quand même qui dépasse
d'ailleurs son
sont qui dépasse le temps imparti ce qui
arrive assez régulièrement au président
qui n'est pas spécialement économe de la
parole présidentielle c'est un je crois
que c'est une prestation techniquement
bonne sans sous le président a été
l'orateur a été dynamique énergie
présent
très concentré
très bon on peut dire dans les trois
quarts de la mission on y reviendra un
peu plus faible à la fin est-ce la
fatigue ou est-ce le choix des sujets
peut-être que tout y contribue donc
c'est un un bon Macron que je crois qui
techniquement qui voulait envoyer un
message sur la question du Cap c'est à
dire dire je suis un je suis toujours là
deux j'ai des idées claires voilà c'est
la question qui a envie de vous
d'ailleurs qui a demandé est-ce que vous
avez toujours un cap voilà c'est
évidemment évidemment ça alors
malheureusement ou heureusement enfin je
sais pas comment les Français
l'interpréteront il y a pas de sur ce
CAP puisque c'est comme il nous l'a dit
et finalement comme il lui a dit à la
fois en général et en détail toujours
libéré protéger en même temps libérer
protégé avec eu quand même une grosse
assistance depuis on peut dire la crise
covid sur la protection des Français
parce qu'il y a quand même quasiment une
demi-heure au début de l'émission l'état
vous aidera l'état vous protégera l'État
sera là on peut multiplier les citations
nous avons décidément un état formidable
oui parce que la première partie de
l'émission était concrètement fait sur
l'économie sur comment l'État va aider
les Français on a eu cette mesure les
prélexités alors les prix de
l'électricité et du gaz vont connaître
une hausse de 15% a-t-il dit et du coup
les PME quoi collectivités locales il y
aura quelque chose pour amortir le choc
donc l'État va aider à ce niveau là
alors l'état et l'État français vous
savez il est quand même merveilleux
puisque c'est visiblement le seul État
au monde qui arrive à aider sans limite
parce que j'ai de constater que il y a à
peu près donc une demi-heure sur l'aide
de l'État il y a exactement une minute
j'ai chronométré sur la question de la
dette et des déficits une minute bon je
crois que ça en dit long la journaliste
n'est pas une journée spécialiste de
l'économie ça se passe de la politique
donc elle est sensible aux questions
d'opinion publique aux questions de
rhétorique politique elle est sensible
aux enjeux des sondages mais évidemment
la question de la dette et du déficit
mais évidemment pas au cœur de ces
préoccupations
donc là le président est très à l'aise
là-dessus puisque
les questions gênantes ne lui sont pas
posées on est bien d'accord sur sur la
dette française soutenabilité sur le
rôle de l'Allemagne très peu de choses
finalement sur le fait que est-ce que la
France a encore la garantie allemande
pour ça pour son endettement enfin les
questions qui gênent sur ce sujet comme
sur finalement tous les autres n'ont pas
été posées ce qui quand même permet au
président d'avoir la main plus facile
vous êtes sur une intervie de façade de
la part de Caroline on a interview qui
n'est pas extrêmement intrusive je
prendrai que que trois exemples arrivés
à parler quand même d'énergie pendant un
bon quart d'heure sans mentionner ni
Fessenheim ni le programme de fermeture
de 12 réacteurs et tout de même un tour
de force arrivé à parler d'immigrations
et délinquance sans évoquer l'affaire
Lola est un peu surprenant donc on peut
pas dire que les questions étaient très
gênantes ou encore sur l'immigration le
président s'y précis
mentionne un certain nombre d'aspects de
l'immigration mais ne parle pas
d'immigration familiale par exemple les
journalistes se gardent bien ou le setel
je ne sais pas ce garde bien du poser
une question là-dessus bon donc ou sur
les mineurs isolés enfin on y reviendra
donc il y a une interview qui est
assez finalement assez on va dire on va
dire complaisante mais qui est qui ne
pose aucune difficulté majeure à un
esprit aussi brillant qu'Emmanuel Macron
oui est-ce que c'est le est-ce que
c'était le rôle ici de d'essayer de le
pousser ou est-ce que c'était plutôt de
d'essayer de lui faire expliquer en fait
son programme et ce qu'il avait prévu de
d'expliquer son cap finalement
je pense quand même qu'un journaliste
enfin une interview en face à face il
n'est pas forcément là pour simplifier
la vie du responsa politique il va quand
même aussi puisqu'il y a des questions
qui se posent dans l'opinion il y a
quand même des questions sur les
déficits il y a des questions sur
l'inflation il y a des questions sur
l'immigration il y a des questions sur
la délinquance et on peut attendre que
le journalisme dans une telle émission
se fasse le relais des interrogations
des Français
donc je pense qu'il a pas eu un exercice
extrêmement difficile et que donc et que
par ailleurs il était encore une fois en
forme on va dire alors il y a eu des
questions sur les sur les salaires a
beaucoup été interrogé au début sur les
salaires il est resté sur sa ligne il a
dit je ne veux pas être démago mais je
suis là je suis pas là pour dire qu'on
va rien accès les salaires sur
l'inflation
d'ailleurs on l'a vu
cette remarque je ne veux pas aider ma
Go les fils se touchent les copains font
mieux que nous moi bien que nous
le recours à un vocabulaire assez
familier qui est d'ailleurs qui est pas
un artifice qui est le Macron tel qu'il
se parle je dirais en dehors de en
dehors d'une émission de télévision
et qui veut donner ou donne une
impression de de spontanéité ça c'est
très important et de parler directement
à la façon dont les Français se parlent
donc je pense que que là c'était c'était
pas mal mais là encore une fois il n'a
pas été très gêné par exemple sur une
question très simple est-ce que alors
cet état on n'arrive plus à s'y
retrouver à la fin finalement comme dit
le président lui-même on va rien y
comprendre est-ce que cet état cet état
qui peut tout faire dans certains
domaines ne peut rien faire sur les
salaires
on tire toujours plus très bien c'est à
dire que c'était à tout puissant d'un
seul coup n'est plus puissant et alors
là sur d'autres sujets n'a plus aucun
pouvoir donc
par exemple c'est une invitation
importée de l'extérieur un impôt de
l'extérieur j'ai noté l'expression c'est
très discutable ça un économiste un
journaliste économiste ou un économiste
dirait tout de suite elle est pas
seulement apportée
est-ce que on aurait pu se dire que la
prochaine fois on continue comme
celle-là on ramène le journaliste en
chef de l'économie de France 2 pour
interroger les Macron j'ai un peu
tendance à penser que là c'est une
question demeure journalistique dans
dans nos différents pays j'ai un peu
tendance à penser que sur
l'international il vaut mieux un
spécialiste dans l'agenda que sur
l'économie vaut mieux journaliste de
l'économie et sur les questions
proprement politique d'ailleurs on l'a
vu sur la question de des votes de
l'assemblée sur la question du Cap
Karine dru est tout à fait là dans son
rôle donc je pense qu'en effet peut-être
un petit problème de l'habitude français
de donner tous ces interviews à des
journalistes politiques qui connaissent
parce qu'on peut pas tout connaître
plus certains sujets que d'autres et
notamment les sujets économiques
on l'a entendu parler aussi du Conseil
national de la refondation une grande
conférence sur le partage de la valeur
au moment de au monde total on en
reparle une nouvelle fois je crois que
ça c'est un petit peu une obligation
pour le président de remettre sur la
table son conseil national de la
fondation qui faut bien le dire à quand
même fait cheat pour reprendre une
expression bien connue c'est à dire que
à part lui et encore j'ai envie de dire
qui croit à ce CNR un peu mal nommé qui
a l'air de doubler le Parlement enfin
qui fait un peu grand débat bis quand
débat qui n'a pas laissé un immense
souvenir qui était très réussi sur le
moment mais les gens se disent mais à
quoi ça a servi alors vous savez des
conseils national de la refondation sur
le partage de la valeur je crois que ça
échappe à l'entendement de beaucoup oui
alors on l'a vu en plus France 2 passer
des petits reportages pendant on a vu
par exemple cette mère de famille qui
parlait justement qu'elle n'arrivait
plus à vivre et qui terminait
son interview sur les en parlant de ceux
qui touchaient les aides sociales et qui
pouvaient gagner de l'argent pas comme
elle et quand il roule par exemple de la
part réinterroger sur ça il n'a pas eu
besoin de de pareil ça non il a pu
barthellé ce qui moi me paraît être
l'axe majeur en fait du macronisme on va
dire socio-économique
en tout cas le cap qui d'ailleurs encore
une fois est le même
c'était donc ces gens-là ne sont pas en
situation de gouverner en revanche il y
a une autre solution qui paraît jouable
et d'ailleurs il a même ébauché un
programme je regarde bien très
rapidement et brillamment finalement
avec elle est on pourrait voter j'ai
noté sur le travail sur les retraites
sur les migrations et sur l'énergie
électrique je pense qu'on peut
travailler avec les parlementaires LR là
c'était assez incroyable c'est-à-dire
véritablement un programme de coalition
oui alors je pense que ça va ressortir
demain dans les commentaires oui alors
c'était une main tendue alors il l'a dit
aussi cela avait été recherché par la
première ministre dès le début en fait
il a essayé d'aller du côté des lèvres
avant la législative pour essayer de
former
ça certainement vrai mais l'essentiel
c'est que ça sorte maintenant en tout
cas c'est à dire que les extrêmes
s'étant allié dans le vote d'une motion
de censure et bien appelle à la France
raisonnable en fait et et au bon moment
opportun bien lancé à un moment donné où
elle est en pleine élection de de son
nouveau président au moment où on sent
qu'il y a peu du un peu de l'hésitation
sur la conduite à tenir au moment où
elle est a eu du mal à expliquer son son
vote ou son vote de la motion de censure
le président la met un coin dans le
dispositif
c'est une avec en plus alors quelque
chose d'assez subtil de subliminal qui
est le déris juste derrière le
référendum et puis toute façon j'ai le
référendum et puis toute façon j'ai la
dissolution donc rappeler à des
gaullistes c'est toujours bon de
rappeler que le patron c'est lui donc il
a fait c'était extrêmement j'ai trouvé
ça très habile m'a tendu en rappelant
quand même que attention les gars pour
parler comme lui attention les copains
j'ai le référendum et j'ai la
dissolution et qu'est-ce qu'il a voulu
le général de Gaulle il a cité encore et
les artisans de la Constitution je
trouvais ce passage particulièrement
brillant donc effectivement l'angoisse
sur la partie politique je vais vous
avoir une petite question sur la partie
économique on a été interrogé aussi
longuement sur les retraites sur la sur
la réforme des retraites si on lui a
demandé voilà
jusqu'où est-ce que vous pouvez nous
confirmer ce chiffre il a confirmé il
dit 64 ans on lui a ressorti ce qu'il
disait en 2017 forcément parce que là
ils en est bien sorti bon écoutez il y a
deux façons d'apprécier ça les gens les
experts souriront parce que on sait
depuis 2017 que on savait en 2017 comme
en 2010 comme 2005 quand même 2000 que
les retraites n'étaient pas équilibrées
d'accord ça en dehors de quelques
on va dire analyse du Conseil
d'orientation des retraites qui font
sourire les experts de la question
Emmanuel Macron qui s'y connaît savait
très bien à l'époque ce qu'il en était
mais ça c'est pour les experts il a il a
disons qu'il a botté en touche là dessus
et puis il a proposé
il a utilisé ce qu'on appelle des
arguments d'opportunités mais depuis on
a eu des crises etc tout a changé bon
tout ça on achète où on n'achète pas moi
je souris mais il a surtout proposé
enfin il est sorti du flou
qui lui était beaucoup reproché et il a
mis sur la table on va dire soit 65 ans
soit 64 ans plus trimestre
supplémentaire ce qui revient au même
quasiment ce qui est plus vendable ce
qui est plus esthétique mais ce qui
reviendra au même c'est-à-dire
l'extension du dispositif Touraine comme
on dit vous savez c'est à dire
l'augmentation progressive du nombre de
trimestres nécessaires bref il a mis
là-bas au bon endroit je pense et
maintenant il va être jugé sur sa
fermeté et là d'où alors tout se tient
LR oui parce qu'il va falloir négocier
évidemment il y aura évidemment une
notion de censure avec
avec évidemment une nouvelle alliance
des extrêmes donc le vote élève ou
l'abstention de LR sera décisive il a
quand même dit sur ce point qu'il
voulait négocier alors il a annoncé
qu'il était assez sûr de lui mais qu'on
pouvait bouger à la marge il veut
négocier sur les carrière longue sur la
pénibilité il laisse quand même la porte
ouverte il faut bien sûr donner un peu
de grain à moudre aussi selon
l'expression consacrée et donc on voit
bien que les modalités bon pareil
l'histoire de 64 ans c'est aussi pour
les carrières longues c'est à dire que
si vous êtes plus jeune vous aurez plus
de trimestres donc il laisse mais sur
l'essentiel il était important qui
disent voilà c'est on va dire allez
c'est 64 ans et 6 mois voilà bon
maintenant le cap est fixé on a pas le
Rego winkuli ça nous change des médias
comme le monde de votre de notre
interview alors je ne sais pas pourquoi
mais en tout cas merci en tout cas de
rester avec nous et de nous poser vos
questions n'hésitez pas à poser vos
questions à Christophe devovo qui sera
très content j'imagine dit répondre
ensuite on a parlé
la revanche la Chine est rappelée que
c'était le premier pollueur du monde le
premier émetteur est de très loin de gaz
à effet de serre à aucun moment ça n'est
venu en discussion effectivement on a
dit on n'a pas eu nucléaire sans parler
de Fessenheim tout de même tour de force
tour de force on a parlé du charbon n'a
pas du gaz de schiste il s'est évité une
petite fille à Nicolas Sarkozy là on
sent très bien la
grande enfin bon on verra jusqu'où ça
ira puisque la dernière interview du
Brésil de l'ancien Président je sais pas
comment le l'actuel président de la
prise mais il est clair qu'il a évité
parce que vous savez que c'est soupe
Nicolas Sarkozy que l'interdiction de
l'exploration et de l'exploitation du
gazochiste a été adopté sur la
proposition Christian Jacob donc
ça aurait été amusant de relever ça la
contradiction de l'ancien président mais
il est évident que c'est une
contradiction française au delà des
présidents c'est-à-dire que on avait des
moyens
indépendance énergétique que l'on n'a
pas utilisé quel qu'il soit voilà
effectivement
ensuite on a parlé de la de la santé du
rôle des médecins de la on a il a ouvert
une porte sur les médecins en leur
disant vous pourrez avoir vous pourrez
partir à la retraite sans cotiser c'est
quelque chose aussi qui peut ouvrir des
portes pour d'autres personnes plus tard
oui là j'étais un peu je suis un peu
perplexe parce que
vous savez actuellement que si vous
cumulez un poids et retraite va vous
payez sur la partie emploi votre
cotisation de retraite
c'est à dire que vous contribuez au
système collectif sans gagner de
nouveaux droits là le président a l'air
de proposer un système où vous ne
prierez plus de cotisations de retraite
alors là ça me semble tout à fait
étonnant je crois qu'on aurait dû le
relever les experts le relèveront c'est
totalement contradictoire avec ce qu'il
a dit au début son grand argument pour
dire il faut travailler plus pour
soutenir notre modèle par répartition
alors si les gens travaillent plus mais
ne cotisent pas à ce système par
répartition il y a un problème vous
voyez ce que je veux dire donc là un il
y a un problème de cohérence qui aurait
dû être relevé ou qui le saura mais
surtout il va y avoir un problème là
nous sommes en France de compétition
c'est à dire que des catégories
diverses et variées qui cumulent
l'emploi et retraite vont dire et
pourquoi pas nous oui ça on ouvre une
porte et du coup peut-être que d'autres
gens vont vouloir s'engouffrer dedans
et on va se retrouver avec énormément de
gens qui vont est-ce que il a pas ouvert
une petite boîte de Pandore on peut le
dire moi je pense que c'est c'est pas
extrêmement bien pensé et il était
pourtant très fier de l'annonce
puisqu'il a eu un suspense vous savez
nous avons préparé quelque chose
d'extraordinaire pour les médecins et il
a fini par dire voilà ce système là
plaira au médecin ça c'est sûr
aidera peut-être
à résoudre une partie du problème que
nous avons mais vous allez voir enfin où
je me trompe beaucoup de dès demain les
anciens avocats les anciens professeurs
les anciens tout ce que vous voulez faut
dire et pourquoi pas moi moi je
travaille et pourquoi pourquoi je salue
céder le Bel Canto qui vient de nous
rejoindre une nouvelle fois n'hésitez
pas à poser vos questions ensuite on a
parlé de la de l'immigration il a été
confronté aux chiffres des des aucutés
seulement 5% qui sont qui sont comment
dire vraiment effectués alors là il faut
quand même dire quelque chose toute la
fin de l'émission un petit peu
d'ailleurs précipité par le temps parce
que les deux grands sujets qui sont
immigration et délinquance d'abord un
petit peu de remarque en tant que
spécialiste de rhétorique on sent que
sur ces sujets le président est beaucoup
moins à l'aise et ça se voit dans le
body language ça se voit dans le fait
qu'il lit il prend ses notes beaucoup
plus bien sûr il prend ses notes tu ne
connais pas donc les chiffres par cœur
alors que vous avez vu qu'ils connais la
moindre hausse du quart de delta du SMIC
depuis
1970 d'accord et là il connaît moins le
sujet on sent que ça n'est pas son sujet
et là je crois que dans le body language
de l'attitude on sent que justement ça
n'est pas sa priorité
il faut bien qu'il en parle c'est le
sujet
un des sujets importants de l'actualité
n'est-ce pas mais ça n'est pas son sujet
on le voit bien aussi lui qui est si
précis dans des descriptions des
mécanismes jusqu'à parfois en être en
être un peu lassant quand il décrit
chaque mécanisme pour chaque pour les
voitures électriques là curieusement il
l'oublie un certain nombre de catégories
ça m'a frappé beaucoup il parle
d'immigration il parle de l'immigration
de travail il parle des étudiants il
parle des gens de l'asile et il ne parle
pas de l'immigration familiales qui est
la plus importante immigration en France
la plus importante source d'immigration
on voit bien que là il y a un problème
politique majeur quand il parle des
sources de la délinquance et à
l'immigration
il ne parle pas des mineurs isolés
qui sont quand même à des problèmes
majeurs notamment dans dans l'insécurité
et là il va se faire vraiment je pense
reprendre demain quand il parle la
sécurité sur toi à Paris non justement
ce que montre la situation actuelle
c'est que l'insécurité maintenant
répandue dans toutes les grandes
métropoles et y compris dans des villes
moyennes donc là je pense que sur ces
sujets il a pas été bon oui alors il a
été il a été poussé par rapport à propos
de de son ministre intérieur déjà est-ce
que lui il parle dans sauvagement alors
il a quand même dit la société française
je verrai se retrouver la situation plus
violent voilà et de du plus loin c'est
quand même un aveu de sa part non c'est
la société c'est pas lui oui non mais je
veux dire que lui le le
disent est-ce qu'il l'avait déjà dit
comme ça en tout cas il a un positionne
commentateur c'est pas que le fait on
est même pas si la société plus violente
on lui demande ce qu'il fait quand vous
répondez alors ça s'appelle en
rhétorique un changement de cadrage
c'est-à-dire on l'interroge sur l'action
du gouvernement il répond la société
vous voyez
et ça c'est une des grandes forces de la
rhétorique de manuel la France et qui à
chaque fois il est commentateur de la
situation il peut vous parler pendant
des heures de comment les choses se
passent en Ukraine dans la santé
française sans répondre à une question
sur l'action et les politiques publiques
et vous et vous vous faites quoi il
répond pas à cette question ou rarement
enfin sauf quand je tente de dire jamais
il répond à cette question mais quand il
ne peut pas répondre il fait des
commentaires et ce qui est vraiment dans
sa rhétorique c'est ce qui d'ailleurs
rend les réponses toujours très longues
c'est ce qu'on appelle la
contextualisation vous lui posez
n'importe quelle question il vous fait
un panorama depuis l'origine du monde
sur la planète entière du sujet c'est à
dire qu'il passe un grand oral et il
énumère toutes les aspects du problème
toutes les solutions évoquées et à
chaque fois qu'on l'interrompre pour le
diable mais peut-être qu'on pourrait
répondre à la question et dit mais sinon
on va rien comprendre alors ce qu'on
appelle la contextualisation qui est une
arme qu'on apprend dans les bonnes
écoles françaises est un peu à quelque
chose qui est un petit peu
je dirais une ruse trop connue des
politiques c'est-à-dire c'est une façon
de gagner du temps
de ne pas vraiment répondre au sujet
précis ça ça a d'ailleurs assez énervé
Carvin qui a essayé de le presser il y a
quelques fois il y a tout à fait bien
compris ce qui se passait et qui est
revenu à la charge à plusieurs reprises
mais qui n'a pas peut-être posé les
questions les plus gênantes oui Lucas
qui nous demande de quid des relations
bilatérales avec l'Allemagne alors il
n'a pas vraiment parlé puisque c'était
sur la partie il y a deux semaines là il
n'a pas été trop question en tout cas de
l'Allemagne il en a parlé assez
rapidement sur quelques sujets pour
donner finalement des points de
comparaison mais il n'a pas parlé des
relations en tant que tel
je vais vous récupérer une autre
question oui voilà donc c'était sur la
sécurité il a demandé justement de de
pacifier la société il fallait pas si la
société mais là une fois de plus il n'a
pas donné lui ce qu'il allait faire
enfin il a donné d'acte en tout cas
concret sur ça non rééducation quand je
suis professeur donc quand on a pas de
solution on dit toujours c'est
l'éducation j'avais qui va qui va régler
le problème
sauf les on oublie toujours que
peut-être l'éducation d'abord à
s'occuper
d'éducation et d'enseignement donc ça
c'est la réponse un peu facile là aussi
je le disais la politique pénale par
exemple peut-être que c'est quelque
chose qui relève du gouvernement la
politique pénale pas seulement les
moyens de la justice mais la politique
pénale là c'est encore un sujet qui a
été évacué par le président il pourrait
peut-être changer la politique pénale
pas la question n'a pas été posée
j'avais quelques petites questions de
rhétorique sur la fin est-ce qu'il y a
des petites phrases qui pourraient lui
coûter cher de 2 de ce qu'il a dit des
petites des petites choses qui
pourraient se retourner contre lui de ce
qu'il a dit ce soir je trouve que dans
l'ensemble enfin je vois pas énormément
de à part le lapsus quand on le refuse
de faire le lien immigration délinquance
et il parle quand même de délinquance
etc là on sent que de toute façon toute
cette partie il n'est pas à l'aise il ne
veut pas dire ce qu'il pense ou il ne
pense pas ce qu'il dit ça je rentre pas
dans dans la tête de d'Emmanuel Macron
en tout cas
je pense que ce sera plutôt le le
caractère le contraste entre l'extrême
brillance et et
je brio plutôt d'ailleurs que brillance
encore que avec lui un peu tenir la
place de l'autre le brio est la
précision de tout ce qui a concerné
l'économie le social et puis le côté je
suis je regarde mes fiches
du presque du Marine Le Pen vous voyez
ce que je veux dire je regarde mes
fiches et je ne suis pas très à l'aise
et j'évite la moitié du sujet
et on a vu aussi un petit truc assez
qu'on avait déjà vu il y a deux semaines
c'est le retour des petits graphiques
qui utilisent des petits graphiques pour
bien consécher peut-être un peu encore
gagner du temps voilà vous êtes trop
jeune mais c'était c'est une c'est
toujours la position alors là c'est la
posture
comme on appelle l'élocution en terme
savant c'est-à-dire que et Emmanuel
Macron nous parle toujours en pédagogue
c'est la posture qui avait déjà Giscard
d'estain donc avant votre naissance
effectivement mais c'est une posture qui
est bien connue et qui renvoie alors une
chose qui m'est cher que je vais
développer dans les colonnes de d'un
très bon jeu qui s'appelle Le Figaro
c'est l'idée qui Emmanuel Macron
s'adresse toujours aux Français
d'ailleurs il a tendance à dire vous il
se reprend après pour dire nous mais
comme un prof parlait à ses élèves
le côté saint Simonien c'est-à-dire
cette doctrine qui dit que les experts
détiennent le bien connaisse le bien et
vont le transmettre par une bonne
pédagogie au peuple donc une bonne
pédagogie aujourd'hui c'est avec des
graphiques
alors lui c'est que certains graphiques
sont plus ennuyeux que d'autres et il
s'est un peu ce côté nous avons raison
enfin c'est le camp de la raison contre
c'est plus que le camp de la raison
c'est l'idéologie de Saint simonienne
c'est-à-dire que l'élite et l'élite et
sa chance on l'a vu avec le covid et va
expliquer et si on explique bien les
gens vont bien comprendre et la
politique passera cette conception
pédagogique du politique vient en France
très précisément de Saint-Simon qui est
l'idéologie dominante comme les autres
fois dans les grandes écoles françaises
Ablis techniques et Alena merci beaucoup
Christophe de Vogue d'avoir été avec
nous merci à vous merci à vous les
internets d'avoir été très nombreux à
nous suivre ce soir je vous rappelle sur
le Figaro vous pouvez retrouver bien sûr
tout ce qu'il faut tout tout ce qu'il
faut retenir l'interview inflation
retraite notion de censure immigration
ce qu'il faut retenir d'interview
d'Emmanuel Macron vous pouvez retrouver
ça sur le site du Figaro vous pouvez
retrouver Christophe de Vogue souvent
dans le Figaro puisque vous écrivez
souvent pour nous dans régulièrement
régulièrement pour le dans la colonne
figarovox merci une nouvelle fois
Christophe et je dis à bientôt à mes
azot pour de nos live sur figarolive